le bowling de besançon fait ce week-end
son 20e anniversaire à un bowling qui
vous en souvenez sans doute avait
inspiré et joseph losey pendant le
tournage de son film la truite alors
pour célébrer cet anniversaire un
tournoi international est organisé
depuis cet après midi bernard ans
oui et pour fêter dignement cet
anniversaire en moins de 72 doublette
française et suisse ont répondu à
l'appel des organisateurs bisontin un
détail en passant le tournoi a bien
failli ne pas avoir lieu cette année un
mauvais plaisant ayant en effet avec un
pays où son dernier directement
l'épreuve de paris de clairement et
d'ailleurs que la compétition était
purement et simplement annulé il n'en
était rien évidemment heureusement tous
les joueurs sont aujourd'hui à pied
d'oeuvre le bowling le buzz en soi donc
20 ans à l'époque où il fut construit
c'était le plus grand d'europe et
aujourd'hui encore ils ne sont que trois
en france avec bordeaux et strasbourg
qui peuvent aligner 24.6 les 144 joueurs
évolueront demain soir sur l'ensemble
des pistes les 32 meilleures doublettes
seront qualifiés après cinq tours de
compétition nourrit ligne pour les
phases finales il y aura en finale
demain à partir de midi la consolante
bien sûr la grande et la petite se joint
selon la formule match play sur 11
lignes c'est à dire que chaque doublette
rencontres toutes les autres alors à
suivre tout particulièrement les trois
doublettes des sharks moudou money de
verre montferrand gournay baverel ainsi
que celle aux et madame de besançon
vainqueur l'an dernier et bien sûr bien
sûr le grand favori voire oeuvre du bois
de paris le meilleur joueur français
actuel qui restent d'ailleurs sur un
authentique exploit réalisé dimanche à
lyon
nous avons débuté la saison là depuis
fin septembre
en gagnant trois tournois de suite
équité charcé nous avons battu trois
records de france semaine dernière à
lyon ça j'espère que ça nous allons
faire aussi bien ce week-end record des
six partis au core core 3 parties en
équipe de 2 6 parties en équipe de deux
et personnellement j'ai battu le record
de france sur six lignes
aujourd'hui vous êtes sur un terrain
votre mesure pensent encore qu'on puisse
jamais dire mais on ne peut jamais dire
au bowling les conditions varient
énormément souvent les centres mais là
je pense qu'il ya pas de problème
puisque le le bowling été reçus à passer
entièrement lié à moins de deux mois et
donc je pense que ça entre les très
bonnes conditions donc leur pouvoir
problème
non